if you look at code and compare code to
other editors and that's one thing that
is that makes code stick out from
sublime text or add some and it's
basically our integrated debugger
experience and because if if you look at
like what we provide in encode it's
basically a way that the developers can
build plug-ins for code so you can have
an this integrated debug experience that
a lot of like I would say traditional
Microsoft developers are used to when
they're coming from dotnet inside Visual
Studio the fact that you can set a
breakpoint you can debug your code from
where you wrote it and it's a concept
that from a lot of users that are coming
from the UNIX tag when they're coming
from BIM and text made and other tools
that they don't don't have that
capability available and frankly that's
what I want to talk about today and and
I want to talk about integrated
JavaScript debugging because if you look
at javascript javascript is really that
the language that touches almost every
developer today and I think as you saw
part of the keynote yesterday like we
are doing a lot for for javascript in in
our cloud Asscher javascript is running
inside the browser's we're doing
JavaScript on the servers with node and
and but also like javascript is running
of hardware basically javascript is
running everywhere and yet javascript is
kind of these one of these languages
that is really hard to debug because
there's no great tooling available the
first thing I want to talk about is
debugging server-side JavaScript and
particularly I want to talk about the
workflow a lot of developers have each
and every day when they're debugging
node code and because it's basically a
lot of consoles are logging and we do
this like a gazillion thousand times a
day break stop our process and some
console logs and continue and the
interesting thing when we actually look
at like what it work what a typical
developer workflow is like you start
your editor you open up your your your
project or your code in your editor you
start node from the terminal we had some
console logs this is something it's not
really working you switch to the
terminal you look at the terminal output
to see what your wife's in logging out
then you switch back to your editor and
then you try to fix the problem
and then this is kind of like the
continuous process are you doing pop you
have a few hundred a few hundred times a
day right and and kind of like what
we've been asking ourselves on the
JavaScript analytics team is like can we
do better and it's a better way and and
frankly that is and there's a way that
we shipping outside of a if if that past
part of the box for code actually and
that's basically our BS code note
debugger that's we're shipping as a part
of the product and in basically what
this debugger does is it enables FIA's
code to connect to your node process and
enables you to have like a rich
integrated debugging experience that a
lot of like I would say traditional net
developers are used to and you can
actually just press a five inside code
and you can debug your code by setting
at a breakpoint you don't need to do the
console locking nightmare that a lot of
us are actually doing um and basically
if you look at like what what this kind
of experience provides it provides a
more holistic 'le integrated experience
where you can start your edit so you can
open your code you'll actually start
know directly from the editor you can
set breakpoints and you can debug your
code straight from the editor instead of
doing all the console locking and then
you can actually fix your problem from
your editor so you actually don't need
to leave the editor but you have like
this integrated workflow that the that
we have seen a lot of developers are
quite happy with but it also makes them
really productive so I just want to show
like a quick demo and is there anyone
here that that is using node out this
debugging experience every day that's
the only a few hands so this is X it's
pretty good so Jax demonstrate it and I
should probably plan to bump the font
size is this good cool so basically what
I have here is that I have a simple and
node application this is my server dot J
s and my server JS file is it's pretty
simple it's a it's a little Express app
that is having a timezone a API endpoint
and Jaycee just returning some data
making it a power crystal showing some
data and if I have a problem in this
like in my traditional way I would be
adding a lot of console logs and start
and restart my cross
but what I can do with but vias code is
that I can't go to the debugger tab here
and then what you see here is that I
have a node configuration I can also say
add configuration and then you can see
here I can choose from some templates on
how I configure the debug on vias code
I've already done this so what I have
here is little a JSON blob little object
that describes how vias code should be
connecting to note I want to like a
launch node I want to use a new protocol
con inspector how to charge in at the
moment and then I'm gonna I want to run
NPM and I want to run call in came with
run script and my start script and I
want to use integrated terminal inside
vs code so with this little
configuration in place I can go to the
to the debugger here and and I can just
press this little green button and what
you're seeing down here is it's
basically my node service booting up
starting my process takes a little while
to startup and now my application is
booted what you see down here is
basically that all the terminal output
is out put it inside the integrated
terminal so as you don't need to leave
vias code here and what I think can do
is that I can just go to my server and I
can set a breakpoint in my API request
and then I can try to use my my demo
application here that is basically
little time zone converter so I wanna
for example at San Francisco and now you
can see now I'm breaking on my code
directly inside vias code I don't need
to add any like console logging to
figure out what's going on and I can
first and we'll see that I got actually
my my request from the API I was calling
if I go to the debugger UI I have the
full call stack where I can go back in
time or basically I can swap between
stacks if I want to I have like
variables everything you kind of used to
from any other browser diff tool but you
just have it integrated as a part of
your editor and what we're seeing here
is that you have a much more efficient
workflow because you don't need to leave
the editor and stand to stop your
process so this is this is just a quick
demo on how that actually works but but
if you look at like the some of the more
recent work we've been doing is like
node 8
it's just around the corner and no date
is introducing a breaking change sir
it's introducing a new a remote
debugging protocol a new way that
editors relic schools can talk to node
and they call this the inspector
protocol and I just want to say like
that our debugger is already working
with no date and and what I demonstrated
here was using inspector protocol so we
already up to speed in terms of like
enabling that support and another thing
like we've been asking are like what
about trying side JavaScript what about
all the JavaScript that we actually ride
outside of your server context and and
actually if you take a look at like the
workflow again and for client-side
developers it's actually much more
complicated because usually the time
site developers they open the browser go
to the editor navigate to the app in the
browser then they also can like try to
find the same files inside the editor
they make a change inside the editor
like I need to go to the browser refresh
the page then they probably need to open
the browser dev tools look in the
console and script debugger to find what
the error was then they go to the
debugger
inside the dev tool find the same file
you just open inside the editor then
they set their breakpoint there then the
debug in the browser the dev tool
regardless if it it ships with Firefox
de tolosa chrome dev tools and then once
you have like narrowed down what the
problem is you switch back to your
editor and then you fix your problem and
the interesting thing when we actually
outline this kind of rather complicated
bit development workflow is that as a
web developers we kind of just use to
this because hey this is how we debug
stuff it's something we don't think
about and the more interesting thing is
like when we actually talk to web
developers and we notice the thing that
that a lot of web developers don't
realize that this is actually a problem
there's a more efficient way of working
we kind of call this the bit developer
Stockholm Syndrome that is perfectly all
right you students have and switch
between browsers editors and terminals
and the good thing is like we spend a
little time like last year trying to see
is there anything we could do about this
problem so a vs code also has like this
marketplace of extensions and and what
we did was we released a a chrome
debugger basically extension you can
install if you want like an integrated
browser
debugging experience inside vias code it
turned out that is one of our most
popular debuggers because a lot of
developers actually want this experience
and our chrome debugger is it's a bit
interesting because it can debug
client-side code the code but it's also
framework agnostic because it's just a
JavaScript debugger it can set a
breakpoint in JavaScript code but
there's this interesting like paradox
that arises when we do clients like code
is that the code the rewriting and what
the browser is seeing is quite different
like we are compiling our code with
transpilers and we're sitting in in
framework abstractions are sitting in
JSX and then the browse of seeing HTML
so we actually spent quite a bit time on
figuring out a way where we can build
the debugger that is based on source
maps and basically what our debugger is
able to is that we can basically like
map the served asset that the browser
the runtime is seeing through your
source files and we do this completely
transparently the only thing like you
need to do is that you need to tell the
debugger this is where my source files
are and then we try to figure it out for
you
and if you look at like if you compare
that to the workflow we have before then
like
browser debugging with this is much more
simple you open your editor
find the file editor you browse European
basically open your browser from the
editor you can debug inside the editor
you can set your breakpoints you and you
can have like this holistic experience
without leaving the tool and you can fix
your problems right within and then
another thing that we're doing is
basically we are able to because we can
so SMAP a deserved code to to you to a
real source we can also show errors in
line inside the code where you wrote it
and I think it's like this is a lot to
check so it's a bit easy to show a demo
in terms of how how this works so if I
go back here like my
my debugger here or vias code is still
connected to my node process but then
what I can do is that I can go to my
launcher JSON and then I can add like a
configuration on how to connect to
Chrome and basically what you're seeing
here is basically the similar configured
say hey I want to launch Chrome key
barking when I launch Chrome and this
you well this is my bit route this place
where my source code is located
what I think can do is that if I go to
the debugger tab I can now switch select
chrome up here and if I press the green
button what you're seeing is an instance
of chrome opening here let me just
resize my windows what I think can do is
like I can go to my client side code
that's in this case it's just a react
app application is used in VIP pack is
using it actually build and talk about
crater II react that from Facebook so
kind of like a standard like packaged
app what are they can do is that I can
actually go to form or one of my
components here that is a place
component that is showing like a place
in the world and what I can do is that I
can first I'm find on time table click
and set a breakpoint when I then
double-click in and in my browser what
you'll then see here is that we actually
sell chrome hey we post initial studio
code and what you have here is the same
debugging experience as you had before
with node but now we're actually
debugging your client-side code and if
you go into the debugger here you can
basically see that our call stack is
like we're still connected to know down
here but now we're paused and chrome so
now we kind of visual studio right now
screws to the coach can I both to know
process and the chrome process what you
have here is like it the same experience
you can step over code you can see like
local variables changing but the key
thing here is that you don't need to
leave the editor and you can connect
this to tray in any instance of Chrome
that is running locally the thing like
this is a really powerful workflow is
that we can actually bring this into
integrate experience inside the editor
and you'll need to open up another dev
tool but kind of what we've been asking
ourself you ladies like it's a better
way can we even do more and that is more
efficient than this and that is because
if you look at like how a lot of us are
building applications today like we
won't life editing we won't like a live
editing refreshing experience and and
basically what we released a few months
ago is basically we added support for
basically real-time updating of source
maps so if you're bundling system like
VIP package is supporting hot module
reloading our debugger supports that so
basically we've got
going from like a workflow where you
need to make a change switch to the
browser refresh see us all switch back
to vias code so where you can make a
change see the result and you can fix
your things right away so these are more
like much more efficient workflow when
you're debugging and basically that the
live editing mechanism I want to
demonstrate here is it based upon big
packs hot module reloading if you're
using another bundle that has a similar
mechanism and then our debugger works
with it but our debugger self does not
do all the live real magic it's
basically up to how what kind of bundle
of what you use it in your system what
we do is that we read the source map
that is generated and emitted and then
we handle it from there so this is
basically enables us to be like bundler
/phraeu framework agnostic and
out-of-the-box we're working with react
boilerplate we're working with a crate
react that we're working with the
angular boilerplates
so because we platform agnostic here and
in this demo that I'm showing I'm using
a crate reactor we are part of the
documentation and all that stuff and but
like let's just show like how this this
actually works so what I have here is
chrome and my application so if I try to
like add if I'm a new place or PSA
sanfran my incident is working can I say
Copenhagen interesting come on internet
yeah there we go so what you see now is
like first of all I'm breaking on my
server side code right now so I'm
basically doing the API request but what
you see now when I step go here is that
now we're breaking on the client-side
code running inside Chrome and what
you're seeing now is as actually a type
error
so we're basically sourcemap the stack
trace or the file from the stack trace
identified that in the editor I'm
pointing you to that specific line where
the error occurred and telling you
what's wrong cannot read the property
addresses of undefined and if I look at
my response data here response that data
then I have addresses I am purposely
introduced I get data data error so if I
remove this and press save what you then
seeing as soon as I continue is that now
live reloading kicked in and if I do the
very same
thing again then my API endpoint is
being hit and San Fran was added
I never lead needed to leave the editor
but have a holistic integrated life
editing experience and I can do this
across stacks I can break in my
server-side code and in my client side
code I think this is this pretty cool
but then we asking ourselves like is a
better way than this and that is because
we will use the feature that we call
compound JavaScript debugging that is
basically a more integrated experience
where you can start both your
client-side debugger and your
server-side iboga at the same time and
and this basically is what we call like
Giavanna JavaScript debugging because
you have one configuration file you
click f5 and then everything boots up
and the way this works is is actually a
relatively simple so if I go into my
vias code launch file here we have
something we call compound and which is
basically just a configuration that
allows you to say my new deeper target
here is full stack and by the way when I
mean full stack you should start my node
config and my chrome config and and what
you then see here I just need to kill
one yeah like that umm what you then see
if you go to the deeper guys that you
can now select full stack and when you
press a go here what we're seeing is
that chrome is starting my node service
booting up now it's like doing the the
react stuff and then Isis seeing my
application but it's all integrated and
now I have the exact same debugging
experience as before but I just press f5
once and we can start up different
targets and I think this is really
powerful because this gives you like
this nirvana integrated experience that
a lot of us developers really want and
but the more interesting thing about
this like vs code is build on a flexible
architecture so this means that this
this scenario is not only enabled with
chrome and a node you can also do it
with our c-sharp debugger and Firefox
you can use our go debugger that that
the community has built with edge
because we have an edge debug available
we basically just come
Hosting different debugging
configurations together that and because
we we have like these debuggers
available we can give you this
integrated experience and I think now I
have like 40 seconds left here I think
what I've shown today is that we have
gone from this much to typical debugging
workflow to a much simpler bit
development workflow if you build modern
applications the application I just
demonstrated before is actually two
separate applications it's a server-side
part and it's usually an API running on
one specific power and it's using
another web server running serving my
clients at front-end in theory I could
be debugging configuring my debugger to
debug a cloud instance I could debug it
on another machine and and if you look
at the workflow with the few lines of
configuration then we have a much
supercharged but also a much better
experience so my my ask for you is that
I would love you guys for you guys to
try it out give us feedback and about
what you think about this and and that's
basically what I had to talk about today
yeah the vs code booth is over here we
also have a Visual Studio Diagnostics
booth and so if you want to talk about
debugging and have any ideas or ways we
can improve things please let me know
thanks
[Applause]